[Music]
um
welcome back to the breakthrough
the the fight viper in sherman oaks mr
tommy bechtold
this is our daily show that keeps you
updated on what's going on in nerd news
and as you can already tell the format's
a little different today we're coming at
you remote uh we're not in our beautiful
actual break room at new rockstars hq
but as a bonus
we're all comfortably at home and we get
joined by the wonderful mr eric voss
hello
thank you guys for letting me come back
in after i screamed at some of the nice
people who were tuning in on our first
episode
it's redemption hour for me no no that
that's the boss we want back i think we
want we wanted your vitriol and rage
lean in baby lean in
and and of course i'm joining my other
co-hosts jessica clemens and tommy told
yes definitely in our real houses
stop it
tommy tommy may or may not be in the the
back aisle of a target somewhere
they'll never know
uh coming up on today's episode we're
really excited to talk about we've got
uh some more info on ms marvel's powers
which we've frequently speculated about
on this uh channel we're we're talking
book of boba fett we've got a little uh
squid game season two update and a whole
lot more and as we've been doing uh on
most of the episodes of the break room
so far we've got our swear jar going and
uh we were trying to explain it to eric
right before we started our swear jar is
a bit of a reverse swear jar in that we
can only swear when we hit a certain
amount of money once we get to uh
multiples of a hundred dollars in the
super chat that unleashes one
um you know tight tirade of profanity
from whichever host happens to notice it
first now tommy is eagle-eyed on that
and has gotten it maybe eight out of the
ten times that we've uh hit it uh
jessica is probably a close second she's
equally observant i'm terrible at it
maybe eric and his eye for easter eggs
and missable details will be able to
notice that square jar
uh
but first let's do the headlines
uh
bang the the graphics probably rolling
right now great uh the news of the day
uh a featurette in today's usa today
revealed that miss marvel's powers
include the ability to manifest light
of course that's very different from the
comics uh but it kind of as kevin feige
pointed out in an interview it more
closely aligns her and strengthens the
connection to captain marvel
oh yeah because we have uh monica rambo
right like she can manifest energy right
so now it's like that's kind of a
similar power set it feels like
the marvels are all uh energy producers
clean energy
i think so long as kamala khan's uh
manifesting of light has a more of a
tangible texture to it i think that's
one thing that like i missed out from
while watching captain marvel and monica
rambo a bit in one division it was just
the actors are clearly like so i just
wave my hands around and then you coat
it with with glow stick goo cool cool
no sorry boss it seems even though
they're trying to get rid of the fact
that like oh she doesn't have the same
powers as mr fantastic as in the comics
she was like super stretchy she's still
super stretchy in the form of super
light does that make sense it seems from
the trailer that she's still extending
her arm but it's the light that is being
extended so i still think she's staying
pretty close to the comics as much as i
really want her to but
jessica piggybacking on that i think
like one of the things that through
three
you know
varying degrees of quality fantastic
four films the stretchiness has not yet
quite been mastered by special effects
and cgi artists whereas the kind of like
manifestation of things like power and
electricity and light is much more i
think uh impressive on screen the
stretching is still even in uh spoiler
alert uh incoming um
uh in multiverse of madness it's it's
better but it's still not quite like as
amazing as i think people who are love
the comic books want it to be so to me
this is almost more of a practical
decision too yeah
yes yes as long as she just says
embiggen at some point
elongate also tommy how dare you not say
four fantastic four movies if we're
including the uh
previously seen on bootleg breakdowns uh
early 90s
all 40 000 of you that supported that
video i know each one of you by name and
you are all still receiving your uh
roger corbin's fantastic four
autographed tommy beck told uh thank you
though
[Laughter]
all right a new photo of jessica jones
actress kristen ritter and luke cage
actor mike coulter posing together uh
was posted recently and it kind of
sparked some rumors of a defender's
reunion we've got more kind of netflix
defenders uh news coming up shortly um
do we think that this could be hinting
at a new project together with those
characters or are these just two friends
hanging out and working two friends
hanging out uh there's another there was
another photo that came out of two
celebrities hanging out with people like
uh and it's like no they even said
they're like no we're just friends
because we had very close scenes
together
no i don't think anyone in los angeles
are friends they're all either future or
present work colleagues
have any conversation any party you know
over
coke that you've done it's whatever
you're working on right everyone's
always on the clock well you know i mean
this true hollywood stories 12 years ago
a photo of myself and nick schwartzen
surfaced on facebook only for us to both
star in bill burr's immoral compass on
the roku channel me as that guy and me
and him as i believe cat murderer so if
you say
people can't come together to make great
content
it feels like a real life it's like a
real-life version of the secret
right
i didn't get a photo but i once saw mike
coulter at the studio city la fitness
yeah uh
a large uh healthy looking man zach zach
huddleston on season two of defenders
confirm
confirmed uh speaking of defenders as we
mentioned this news kind of just broke
right before we started recording
variety is reporting
that a new disney plus daredevil series
is a go
uh no details yet no casting news they
just kind of assigned some show runners
to it um and you know we don't know
dates anything like that but
it is being worked out i said new
daredevil series so it's not following
up what netflix had put out hey we don't
know what was the headline writer from
the uk because they called season series
there
look at them look them up look them up
and maybe it would be considered as a
new series just because there was a
break maybe this would be called
daredevil man without fear or something
you know it'll have a slightly different
title to note that it comes from a
different studio or maybe it has a
different this could be 616 daredevil
because i mean charlie cox in interviews
has theorized that his daredevil from
the netflix series and the daredevil
that he played in far from home are may
not be the same person right eric i
think i we you know
don't quote me no i'm not quitting you
because
you've also seen that i think there is
i
you know interviews people he said it
off-handedly in an interview he didn't
say like
yeah he said it at a uh at like a uh i
believe was in tel aviv or something
like that a uh a comic-con or some kind
of convention and to me it was very
clear that he said that like the charlie
cox and spider-man no way home and
coming up in uh in the mcu is going to
be like a different universe variant
like that was absolutely the context but
don't tell that to the people who
believe that everything that happened in
the netflix daredevil show is a hundred
percent mcu successfully
because they will take him out of
context and yell at you
and send all your hate to me
because you want to know what i fuel off
it nerds i fuel off it oh
the will the wilson fisk of the break
room right there
your tears lubricate my captain crunch
so it can slide down my throat and not
make so many cuts like rock
a lot about this we'll probably even
have some content on the channel
speculating about it especially when we
get some more news about casting and
dates and things like that um and now we
have been uh talking a whole lot about
all of this vanity fair star wars
coverage uh over the last couple days
you know the kathleen kennedy interview
lots of news both about upcoming star
wars releases and kind of previous ones
uh one thing we got into john favreau
defended the decision to make boba fett
a good guy in the book of boba fett
right uh he was quoted as saying i think
he's just wise he's also a much older
character because now uh we're after the
original trilogy he's at a very
different point in his life having
experienced what we had seen in all the
previous films um
now tommy and eric are making a uh very
special star wars themed
trip yeah fingers crossed uh we we're
going to we're knowing our honeymoon but
thank you for calling it a trip yes
our
honey2 moons
zach's paying respect for our uh our
relatives back east who don't really
know me and tommy's true relationship
yeah we're just friends going on the
trip these two buddies heading up to
space mountain
celebration in anaheim fingers crossed
that it doesn't get cancelled by act of
god or covet or something like that but
um yeah uh do you do you have thoughts
on on this quote or what are you most
let's just take a quick side trip what
are you most excited to see at star wars
celebration well i do have thoughts on
this interview because i read the whole
the whole article uh and i think that it
expounded upon favreau made it's kind of
some even more salient points that like
it's interesting he did a lot of
comparisons to michael corleone from the
godfather like you know which is kind of
a funny like let me compare this
character i made to one of the greatest
characters in cinematic history however
what what he was saying was kind of like
a reversal where like boba fett was born
destined to be a bad guy right like he's
the son of like a merciless bounty
hunter who is orphaned at a young age
and then kind of raised in the shadow of
the empire ultimately when the money is
right or the credits are right joining
the empire in their in their uh
in their in their pursuit of the of the
rebellion only to kind of just be cast
aside and left for dead in the stomach
of a sarlacc making kind of a boba fett
haggis if you will and
you know so he said the interesting
choice rather than having him just
continue to be you know a ruthless
nerd-to-well bad guy why do you want to
who would really want to follow that
story uh immediate tweets from uh angry
people
we do uh on my twitter timeline but he
said it's more interesting to make him
as he said than continuing on with that
why score like he has so much knowledge
now about why
doing things from an evil or a bad point
of view don't work that it makes sense
for him to want peace it makes sense for
him to want you know kind of justice to
do what's fair rather than what is uh
ultimately more profitable so no longer
driven by money it's easy for him to be
a little more benevolent i think
yeah i was okay with that moral
alignment shift for the character
because ultimately i think boba fett in
the original trilogy was more of a
neutral character we don't really know
what his motives were um he wasn't
necessarily a villain he was just a guy
in a gig uh and as we know we've done
plenty of gigs before in front of all
kinds of possible audiences and who
knows what that brings out of here
you're looking at a man who's never
wanted howlers i wish i could have
frozen a car tonight i could haunted
house in orange county once where
not one not two not three but four
people showed up in blackface so i've
done some real hell kicks before
i mean philip has a hilarious story
about how he did a haunted house in
college and completely he's like oh i
will be completely uh pitch black and
then basically just put a black paint on
his face and rode a bus to the gig uh
i'll let him tell that story uh
anyway i just wish we bring it back to
boba here
i do wish that we got to see
more of his wisdom i think like in those
episodes he just made so many tactical
blunders trusting people he should not
have trusted to begin with like i think
they're kind of looking back on their
writing of that series with some
rose-tinted glasses i think that when we
covered it it wasn't his like gaining of
a conscience it was complete loss of
instincts that was more
jar
like oh he's now got like a sense of
purpose it's like oh he forgot how to
like deal with the people he dealt with
his whole life very effective yes
and and and yeah maybe that comes down
to intent versus execution and i don't
think it was a bad intent maybe it just
wasn't quite executed the way they would
have liked the way we would have liked
but um yeah but now what what are you
excited to see it uh star wars
celebration next week
i've never been to a celebration before
i i'm gonna be a complete noob and i'm
so excited to see the the cosplay
because like uh the the people like star
wars celebration is really the epicenter
of the like people who will just go from
con to con like with the most amazing to
me like the most exposure i got to great
star wars cosplay was when i lived in
north hollywood and there was the guy
with the silver mandalorian armor on the
skateboard oh you guys are seeing that
guy i see him i see him almost every
week
[Laughter]
he's awesome
um
so yeah i'm just i'm excited for the uh
for and i just want to see like the
vendor room like there will be oh tommy
and i found out we're going to get
access to the thursday lucasfilm panel
so i think that's where we're going to
see an andor panel but like obviously
you know we're used to just seeing stuff
on youtube when it drops but being able
to see the
the the teams in person as they're
talking about their process i'm just so
i i echo those this is uh not to brag uh
or cry for help my fourth
fourth celebration uh
but i uh i think what i'm really looking
forward to the costumes are always
amazing the vendors are incredible
especially the artists that make their
own like basically
incredibly incredibly incredibly high
quality fan art but sat friday eric and
i have access to a panel that has
lawrence kasdan and ron howard in it and
i'm sorry whether you like solo or not i
will listen to ron howard talk
filmmaking all day any day about it like
i i you know and as someone who's not
like a a really die-hard solo hater uh
someone who kind of i actually kind of
enjoyed the film i uh
i'm just looking forward to that i mean
all the panels that erica and i are
lucky enough to have access to sound
amazing but that panel in particular i'm
like man that is a once in a lifetime
really close up to that i i'm so excited
for that i i really you know i think
it's going to hopefully be some good
opportunities for eric and i to share
uh what we learn at these things and uh
hopefully make some fun content as well
not that that won't happen learning
isn't fun but let's face it
a little bit of a snooze so uh
why
colleges no degrees baby
yes we're we're we're still working out
the details but we hope we'll maybe have
some kind of reporting back uh from your
experiences maybe some content to share
here on the break room certainly on uh
wikileaks the show that eric and tommy
host every week and that that show's
gonna be blowing up real soon with the
uh release of obi-wan and really
probably throughout the rest of the year
with uh and or to follow and a lot of
good star wars content coming down the
pipeline
but back to back to headlines um squid
game creator and i i apologize i'm not
good at uh pronouncing uh korean names
huang
dong yuk
uh gave more insight into season two in
a recent interview with vandy fair um
these are like great
scary type quotes i feel like i want to
ask the question is true solidarity
between humans possible like oh my god
he's gonna make people do some stuff to
each other you know uh and he added that
the show could be out by the end of 2023
or 2024 humanity is going to be put to a
test through those games once again um
we all loved squid game and covered it
here on the channel very excited for
another season of that show absolutely
yeah
and i say take your time with it please
don't rush it we see this so many times
with like amazing first series of a show
and they like
they'll like true detective was this
right where the show runner just spends
years gestating on this idea and then
they rush a second season and it's just
not as good so i like to hear that like
the end of 2023 or 2024 great no rush
take your time
take your time and let's just make sure
none of us get roped into any
high-profile suicide games before then
god knows i need the money
if you if you meet a man on the at a
subway uh station tommy do not do not
take him up on his dice rolling position
okay not again i'll never do it again
twice was too many um we got a a season
three umbrella academy trailer i watched
this earlier today
it's a great looking trailer um you know
kind of fulfills the teas at the end of
season two for folks that have been
watching that netflix series certainly
kind of blows that out looks like
they're going to explore that uh for the
rest of season three with kind of the
umbrella academy versus the sparrow
academy if you haven't watched that show
very digestible you can catch up on the
first two seasons on uh netflix right
now ahead of that third season premiere
looks like it's going to be a lot of fun
i'm a big fan of that show i actually
enjoyed the comic not to brag uh uh when
it came out god
i think the comic is almost eight or
nine years old now whenever uh gerard
way started young animal with dc but uh
yeah i just like the way that they do
the show i like you said it's very
bingeable it's kind of uh they do a good
job of explaining the world and then
just blowing it out and then this season
you know it's clearly like this is a
great season where like they they kind
of wrapped up the mysteries of season
one in within season two and then just
exploded everything so now fans of that
show i think will be
uh rewarded with a great season three
and i hope new fans of the show will
watch seasons one and two before
absolutely
um oh and then uh this is kind of a
funny story so we're we're also very
excited for another netflix series
coming very soon stranger things uh and
uh
apparently news came out that key plot
details of the upcoming stranger things
season were spoiled via a netflix themed
monopoly set
now we do not know what the spoilers are
and we're not going to talk about them
here uh and actually nobody has talked
about what the specific things are you
probably have to buy that monopoly set
to know but apparently it's so pissed
off the creators of stranger things
duffer brothers that they like created a
big stink and it got us thinking about
how often merch and toys
uh scale movies
it is completely baffling how many times
companies will create products without
asking the people that created the show
they did the same thing too um
what was it uh gravity falls disney
released like a book of unpublished
likes animation cells and they were like
we didn't know they were doing this we
didn't know that they had access to this
yeah so it's just like all these things
that they were planning on doing they're
like what we couldn't do because they
put it in a book
it's so funny like when i was a kid i
had this spider-man notebook and it was
like just a blank notebook and then one
day there was a note at my kitchen table
from my dad saying he was leaving
forever uh from and i was like how did
the spiderman notebook know to write
that
uh that's so crazy that's insane
tommy i don't think that was the
notebook i'm just kidding i'm just
kidding sorry dad if you're watching
that's not that's not
well
eric is it i i know i mean this is
eventually came out in other ways as
well but was it our first
inkling that gore the godbutcher might
be in thor did that come via
some kind of oh we knew we knew that he
was gonna be in it um they they well we
suspected that for a while and then they
confirmed it when uh they did that
disney plus day in like december 2020
but they um they showed us like i think
the first look we saw of like what he
might look like aside from set photos
was like in the form of a lego version
of gore the god butcher and lego will do
this all the time we have a friend a
close friend of ours who we went to
college with who works in conjunction
with marvel in a lot of ways and he says
like
the toys drive them well they're crazy
in the narrative
uh mjolnir
uh revealed that the uh uh mighty thor
character played by natalie portman was
gonna tie into the comic book cancer
storyline like that hadn't been revealed
about about the the movie at all until
the toy came out
yes yeah for sure um stuff with the uh i
remember an infinity war the hulk buster
armor the fact that banner was going to
be in the hulkbuster uh was like it part
of a lego set um for sure with like
eternals with multiverse of madness
there was like a gargantus looking thing
that's how we learned gargantua's name
because otherwise it wasn't specified
uh and we might come or we will
certainly come back to this in a little
uh segment uh tommy likes to call
mandatory fun uh so stick a pin in this
uh there might be more talk of toys that
spoil things um but actually first uh
let's i'm going to move things around a
little bit because i want to talk about
our good friends eboxu who are helping
us um bring this episode to you remotely
eric's actually got a a delicious boxu
there with him he's got the tanjubi box
boxu is a monthly subscription service
that delivers premium japanese snacks
and tea pairings straight from japan to
your door each baksu features a new
theme providing you a little gourmet
journey through the beautiful regions of
japan every month and you have the
tenjubi box tanjubi means birthday in
japanese so this celebrates the sixth
birthday of uh baksu as a company so
these are some of their favorite snacks
over the six years um eric you mentioned
before that you've already kind of uh
gone through a little bit of the 10
jubilee box yourself do you have any
favorites or things you're looking
forward to getting into
i love mochi so much just because like i
as i get older it's less about the
flavor and more about the texture with
foods and like to me the flavor or the
texture of mochi is like the most
pleasant thing ever it's just so
relaxing and calming yeah like a more
like a more toothsome marshmallow if you
will mm-hmm
um
boys
goats
uh we've been digging into all of a
variety of the the different boxy boxes
here all week at uh new rock stars and
actually may is asian heritage month and
kind of a cool thing about baksu is they
work with a lot of like tiny and
family-owned uh japanese snack makers
authentic like family businesses uh
throughout the country and so it's a
cool way to kind of connect to that
heritage and that little booklet that
eric held up a minute ago kind of gives
you a little back story about the
individual snacks and the people that
make them and the part of the country
that they come from uh if you want to
try baksu out and get into the delicious
uh gucci mochis and um other uh good
snacks that come with it go to uh the
link in this video's description uh
use code rockstars to get 15 off your
order you'll not only be getting some
great snacks maybe send in some good
snacks to a friend of yours or a loved
one we'll also be supporting us here in
new rockstars in the break room so thank
you to boxu for helping us out and then
a quick shout out uh to our our friends
at
newrockstarsmerch.com eric is wearing
right now our latest obsession shirt
inspired by
the multiverse of madness that shirt's
called shattered madness as a very cool
fun design i also like how strange's
heart is kind of positioned about where
the actual heart of the wearer would be
yeah
my heart is uh sitting on a slab
somewhere in another country
it's removed and replaced with um a
criminal's heart oh
oh okay there's an icebox where my heart
used to be
oh i love that song
i love omar i was gonna say not a lot of
omarion fans
oh i'm an omarion fan
uh
uh poor man cisco is what i like
okay
now uh
let's let's pivot we're gonna uh
eric's gonna lead us in a a little
discussion about she-hulk yeah so um i'm
i love this she-hulk trailer so much i'm
able to just like put aside my thoughts
about the cgi because i think like the
world that it's setting up and the way
it's connected to the mcu is so cool and
weird and there's a side relationship
that we got to talk about
wong
and his friendship with abomination now
benedict wong was confirmed to be in
this series he's gonna be joining the
cast isn't it crazy that the mcu right
now is really like the wong cinematic
universe they're just putting wong in
everything and i have no complaints it's
everywhere
everywhere you can throw them in
anything makes so funny and he's such a
team player and he's just like the
smartest guy in the room but he's also
like clumsy in the most adorable way i
love wong like give wong a movie wong
needs to get his own title i think but
anyway we got some questions about like
what he's doing in this show um so like
let's
like is it just going to be with
abomination are we going to find out why
he and blonsky have this side
relationship why they showed up in
chiang chi
there just
has to be i am still writing this really
weird theory that
wong is like his sponsor
that like because
we haven't seen an abomination in so
long that i'm sure he's changed you know
when you're stuck alone for a long time
you probably change and people change so
i like to think that wong is there to be
like yeah this is his way of getting
exercise and his way of getting out and
getting that anger that he still has
built in him to get it out we just spar
and as long as we keep sparring he's
fine he's good to go he just needs a
little bit of you know
like
get to get it out so i i really want
one's friend to be there to help him
i i love that idea and i was kind of
thinking something similar right and
like there is a precedent for that both
in like uh parole officers and in like
you know often like you have a sponsor
maybe when you're dealing with addiction
or other things like that there are
people that work with like uh former
service members and stuff like that to
kind of uh help them through trauma i
would love that if like you know the the
sorcerers are kind of have this
spiritual bent can be a little bit of
like uh you know hey i'll be your both
your counselor and your sparring buddy
it's such like a fun weird mix uh of
those two i love that idea seems like
he's a little bit of a father figure as
long as uh abomination will put his tiny
hand in his he could be his preacher
teacher
till the end of time
[Music]
stop him take it away he doesn't know
how whistles work yeah
someone go to his house and rip
i don't like i just i get that and i can
imagine wong being in this mindset of
you know wanting to take these broken
toys and give them a second chance i
think that it's totally something that
the sorcerer's supreme might say you
know what no i believe in redemption in
this mcu i just wonder like is he doing
this on behalf of whoever the warden of
this prison i think it's thecube are we
is he doing this with their permission
is he doing this in spite of their
permission i just don't really know
how much the sorcerer's supreme cares
about the us government
and their interest it has to be in spot
and spot spot just
under
whatever word you use whatever vocab
word you use uh it has to be under the
radar because he's just like
bringing him out right and then sneaking
him kind of back in i get i don't know
maybe because that maybe that's also the
quickest way to get that big lug out of
that room is just to get him out and in
but i feel like it would be easier to
transport him if he wasn't hiding him
you know does that make sense yeah
yeah i think like if it is on behalf of
a warden it's going to make wong seem a
bit like
you know like i imagine this were to be
someone like val you know and if val can
like make wong do stuff like it's kind
of like i feel like wang wouldn't care
if he was like through the government i
feel like he's got his own sneaky thing
that he's doing with abominations i
agree so val is bad
we know val is yeah yeah
i feel like we're we're always on the
fence about whether or not val is bad
because it's like if she does get like
people like florence pugh like elena to
join the team elena's bet or kate bishop
if she got her is kate bishop i
we've gone into some weird stuff in the
break room but
so if she's overseeing abomination
she wants abomination to do bad things
again but he doesn't want to do bad
things if we're going off our theory of
he's getting his anger out correct
right yeah right
well we we don't we don't know right
there's potential here for an amanda
waller
suicide squad situation right we're
technically
well going to starrow is a good mission
now the ulterior motive spoiler for the
film suicide squad right the ulterior
motive beneath the star thing was not
nice so yeah it's tough we don't know
val's true motivations we know she's
kind of extra legal
right like a little bit outside the
system all within the system but kind of
so aren't the avengers right like we
don't know how
bad her intentions might be yeah do we
know i think if she gives johnny
mayonnaise a second chance no one is
good
that's what i mean that's why i'm like
i'm like uh
i don't like this guy i you can't change
val
do we think that she's she's taking the
mantle where thunderbolt ross is leaving
correct
i think so i think so i think ultimately
it's going to be almost a victoria hand
thing going on you know um i think
there's going to be like a dark avengers
lineup and they're going to
let julia lee dreyfus lead that up i
don't know if we're going to see that in
the show i just think ultimately that's
what val is doing
though um i'll say this do you think
wong would be in involved in yeah that's
that's my question i don't know like
wong seems as a sorcerer i don't think
he would care about what the
thunderbolts do like he's got bigger
uh
defry right like i agree um yeah i guess
he kind of sees the
he sees like he's got the he uh what do
they call it out he's he's he's zoomed
way out on the issues right as opposed
to just like we got to get rid of this
one bad guy in this one little place
wong is looking at the world and like
saving the world from a very very wide
angle of like here's a here's a cosmic
threat here's a magical threat here's a
yeah he's got the third eye view instead
of the bird the third eye
yes
no no he's not blind i'll tell you that
much
that's right hey step back from that
ledge my friend is what he's saying to
abomination
uh but he's still taking time out of his
schedule of protecting the multiverse or
whatever to kind of help rehabilitate or
spar with uh
abomination it is interesting right and
that that is like an unusual pairing
also i think and dick wong and um
uh
tim roth are probably going to be really
funny yeah i think they're going to be
sure
i also think we keep saying that they
need to spar to get his anger out i
think wong has also a lot of upset
frustration and he deserves it he has he
has every right to have be so irritated
with everything and just to be like i
need to get it out with boxing but a
punching bag is not going to do it the
only person strong enough abomination
you know what we need we need a scene
where it is uh tim roth as emil blonsky
and wong as wong sitting in a diner at a
restaurant just talking about their
feelings and their anger at the very end
tim roth hulks out into abomination
jumps on the table and says damn it
swear to god's not there yet but how are
you gonna let us move or we'll kill
every last one of them
that's right we get we get sam jackson
nick fury sitting in the same diner say
scroll again
you know i i think like ultimately uh
since wong i can't imagine wong would be
on board with any kind of dark avengers
or thunderbolts or whatever it is i
wonder if his goal is to subvert what
val is doing and he is teaching emil
blonsky how to take control over his
abomination hulk out so that he won't be
forced to be like a super soldier for
someone else's bidding he's going to say
hey so when the time is right now
activate your own self-control and you
can break free
100
right 100 agree i think and and that
will add a lot of depth to that
character when abomination still chooses
to join the darkness
but he will be torn maybe he does have a
legitimate friendship he does he's
getting these characters are much more
interesting when they're getting pulled
in both directions which arguably john
walker has like things pulling him in
both directions right like all it's
certainly uh elena right like they they
are not black and white just straight up
evil villains that's what makes these
characters kind of so interesting to
watch yeah
oh 100 um real real quick i was just
going to throw in
we know we're getting introduced to some
kind of prison for super powered
individuals
any time you get introduced to something
like that i feel like it's setting the
table for a prison break
are we gonna see something like that on
she-hulk i know that that feels pretty
far afield from what that show's gonna
be about but i mean could it be said
more reason to do that she's a lawyer
more reason to do anything that involves
breaking the law she's gonna do it right
now
and she holds she gets them out with
appeals and uh you know evidence and
whatever right not like somebody
drilling a hole through the water i
think that'll be gonna be a breakout
there has to be a break in
um yeah or you know prison break it
starts with they break in really and
then a break out by the end of the
season
but the question is like who else is in
this space you know if it is the cube
it's it's gonna be a type of prison that
uh keeps
uh gamma irradiated individuals and if
that's like a multiple
in individual thing that's where we can
get to a place of like you know a
giant-sized hulk a world war world war
hulk maybe we could see a red hulk in
there uh it's going to be different it
can't be thunderbolt ross at this point
unless they recast um you know rap
william hurt but like they could still
go that angle with just a different
character being red hulk uh this is a
show to do it i think if you're gonna
have abomination there if you're already
spending all this money uh that'd be
anytime you introduce a prison you wanna
see the place explode and everyone break
out absolutely absolutely
absolutely um
so uh one last question you know we we
saw
wong uh last saw wong and banner with uh
with his sling you know in the shang
cheapo's credits scene um we've talked
about that in other videos of course but
do you think uh chung chi as like the
heir apparent to the avengers could show
up on this show
no
no no no i don't i think there's
because wasn't isn't there mention and
correct me if i'm wrong that matt
murdock will be coming in
i think that would be the likely or
mind-blowing gaming of charlie kind of
showed up on this show i feel like
yeah i also think there's just so many
cameos you can do and i think getting
like
abomination already in and out of form
and then you're going to have hulk and
then you got matt murdock i think
throwing chunky and there's another
little bit of like oh this is going
completely the other way
who played uh who played betty ross in
the uh in the 2008 was that liv tyler
liv tyler
i mean are we are we ruling out a betty
ross cameo are we ruling out uh
i mean a return what didn't she do end
game wasn't her wasn't she standing next
to william hurt at the end of uh tony
stark's funeral an end game
oh i i don't know
i don't think so i think he wasn't he
standing alone he was standing by
himself all right hey you know what i'm
right and you guys are wrong no i don't
it could be yeah i'm right you guys are
wrong well there's there's no way for us
to ever know so
tyler was part of that like earlier era
like they didn't bring back ed norton
and i think liv tyler as like his love
interest in that movie it was just too
weird i think william hurt was really
the one actor from that series that they
brought back we'll find out won't we
i just want to throw in uh there was a
super chat from skyler aldridge uh
asking
you know with with william hurt's
passing if they did decide not
necessarily to recast thunderbolt ross
but maybe have a different existing mcu
character turn into red hulk who do you
think it could be i see skyler suggested
val i mean julie dreyfus some kind of
hulked out version of julia look drivers
would be crazy would be awesome wild um
yeah i don't know i i think
uh there's probably some obvious answers
about justin hammer what about a justin
hammer at all oh i can see justin
hammer's still in jail right or probably
from the shore in the short he's still
in the prison not this prison but
a normal prison
i'm i mean this is this is kind of uh a
cop-out answer but anytime you can have
somebody's kid
you know trying to avenge their uh
wronged uh you know aldrich killian's uh
son who we've never seen on film but
he's gonna avenge his father by taking
the gamma radiation or something like
that yeah i think uh i'd be interested
to see other whole figures like uh hulk
lean i know that he's been speculated a
lot he's he's called hulk lane but he's
actually like a half scroll he's not
necessarily anyone's kid uh well he is
someone's kid but not these characters
kid uh and i think it'd be fun to
introduce amadeus cho on the show that
name hasn't been thrown out there a lot
but he's such a fascinating character
and we have helen cho in the universe
but i don't think it's ever been
established that he she has a kid named
amadeus uh like if this is just gonna be
the hulk show like our portal into the
whole corner of the mcu you gotta have
amadeus show in there i think
let's do it baby that's great
uh speaking of things we should do tommy
is it
hang on
i need to cast a spell
mandatorius
it's time for the segment that has swept
the nation hit my graphic again
a segment's so nice we play the graphic
twice
the segment's so fine sometimes we play
it
three times hit my graphic again
we reported earlier those dummies and
parker brothers released a stranger
things four monopoly game that spoiled
some major plotlines from stranger
things season four you know if they were
smart they would have released a recap
monopoly game that reminded us what the
hell happened on that show five years
ago it was last night but that got me
thinking
my three best friends are here
what are some other merchandise spoilers
that have uh you know affected you and i
want to remind everyone that these may
or may not be real uh so uh put your
spoiler hats on and uh i wanted each one
of you to pitch me your your best merch
spoiler past present or future that you
can think of who would like to go first
go on i'll go first
great it's so crazy you guys i was
actually at target the other day
and uh i saw that this is nuts i know
that solo a star wars film was kind of
maligned
uh by critics and and seemingly kathleen
kennedy even kind of bailed on it the
other day in the vanity fair article but
they're actually wait a minute tommy i
hate to interrupt you but
[ __ ] you for saying it was maligned
because we just hit swear jar 106 bucks
yeah
thank you
so bad about the movie 100 it was a
thousand percent rotten tomatoes a
billion dollars in the domestic box i
think it came in second only to morbius
for highest grossing
wow and and shout out to jacob neely who
was rooting that eric noticed the swear
jar first dreams do come jacob is that
one for you well anyway eric i i am a
solo believer i'm i'm maybe the solo
believer uh but i i want a continuation
of the solo star wars film and what's
nuts is i was at target and they have
merchandise for solo too
and they actually have a millennium
falcon
and i bought it wow and it seems like a
regular millennium falcon but when you
open it there are some just absolutely
crazy what i i have to assume are
spoilers because okay let me see how
this thing opens oh god upside down i
know it opens
yeah
okay so what's crazy is
there is an r2 unit in it so that makes
sense oh two's in there
well what's crazy is after that
rough rider teddy roosevelt
rough rider yeah the rock what's up
yeah it's the wrong dimension on teddy
isn't it he's like almost as big as this
why is he blending in with your house
well
he goes away in my house rough rider
teddy roosevelt is flying but that's
that's not all
also co-piloting it taking the place of
what i can only assume is the
replacement for chewbacca is terry from
kiwi's playhouse
this is a major spoiler terry confirmed
terry from pb's playoffs confirmed
and who's going to be the main bad guy
this is crazy because i i thought for
sure this had to be it main bad guy in
solo 2 confirmed batman the animated
series two-face
batman the animated series the two-face
will be the major bad guy and
good guy
in solo
a star wars and i gotta say target
you're done drop the ball
drop the ball
and you ruin the movie for everyone else
we're sorry that happened tommy i'm
sorry
oh no spoke to you yesterday
and i said some things that i regret i
want to apologize to you now
sorry about the bag of blood just feel
free to send it straight back to me
according to my doctor i should not have
sent that much blood and i do need it
back
hopefully you kept it
either refrigerated or at a boiling
temperature because if you send that
blood back room temperature i'm a goner
also if you don't get this reference
that tommy just made i'm sorry you're
gonna have to watch the full one hour
episode from yesterday
um
uh okay well i'll go mine is not as
elaborate or not as prop heavy as as
sadly as tommy's you just did a great
job real quick i want to shout out my my
cousin uh davey fallon who uh had his
14th birthday earlier this week i've
been meaning to birthday shout him out i
hope you're having a great birthday week
down in san diego okay
um mine was this was actually spoiled
for me at my local kroger
uh grocery store right i'm walking down
the canned soup aisles because you guys
know i'm a i'm a campbell fan you love
it right you're saying
oh
yeah so i souped up on soup is what they
call that's that's my super soldier
serum okay so i'm looking through all
the different soups then i see like a
chef boyardee
uh
multiverse of madness themed can okay
cool well i want to buy that but on the
can
they have john krasinski richards
the actual noodles are shaped like his
body flayed into spaghetti that's
shameful and i'm like that's shake not
only did they spoil his appearance they
spoiled that he was gonna die by being
shredded by wanda
horrible
shame on chef boyardee
i will never ever eat that gross ravioli
ever again
that's impossible
[Laughter]
i think that's that's part of an
initiative to keep kids from eating so
many carbs is they want to eat
mr fantastic let me tell you what i've
ate john krasinski before it's not as
good as you think god i can go next i
can go next off that note off that note
off that where's that whistle at where's
that whistle at uh off that note
oops
um you guys
i i had to go to the store
and i had to go pick up some some some
some really cool clothes because you
know how i wear the coolest clothes on
set oh you would have the glow store
yeah aka the hot topic
the hot topic at universal that sounds
like a house
don't let me tell you about it it's a
hot topic so i went to hot topic and i
went in there right and i was like oh
this looks like some brand new swag you
got here they said this is exclusive
from the harley quinn animated series
season four
which
hasn't even really been thought of yet
yeah and i was like whoa i need to go
over there and buy it and the only item
they had left
was this uh
15 milligram of lexapro wow and i said i
said wow
there is no way
this has anything to do with harley
quinn and she said
it's the version of harley quinn that's
the doctor and i went oh my god spoil
[ __ ] i mean oh spoiler but and i got
that because she spoiled me and told me
season four was the the pre
of harley being the doctor and i'm
irritated she's just handing out 15 mils
alexa pro left and right well first of
all let me just say 15 milligrams coward
get up to 40 and then we'll talk
uh enjoy join the 40 gang
and then you can really start zoning out
uh
yeah that's a crazy spoiler shame on hot
topic
shame very careful going through the hot
topic cheers to harley quinn for for
self-care and for taking care of uh you
know this there's absolutely uh
a good thing to to handle depression so
good for her in a way
i'm not as mad about that spoiler as i
am about the uh spaghettis i gotta say
yeah all right eric any spoilers coming
to your life recently yeah i mean uh
everyone knows how how awful it was when
that reporter from variety
tweeted out that harry styles was going
to be in the post-credits scene for
eternals playing thanos's brother aeros
a star fox um but i hate to say it but i
actually got spoiled on that even before
that and i'm not talking about leaks i
was uh getting dinner with some friends
and um a female friend of mine was going
through her purse and just kind of
taking stuff out of her purse and you
know i'm a guy so i don't understand at
all what it what it means to to be a
woman living in uh living in the dangers
of society right now where uh all kinds
of threats are are coming your way and
uh she had something that i kind of
offhandedly and insensitively made a
joke about i'm like what's this and she
goes um that's my rape whistle and gave
me a very uh respectful and uh patient
uh
discussion and explanation of what that
is and i said but wait a minute who is
on this and she goes well i just
got this handed out uh to me at uh
at disneyland and i was like really into
stealing she's like yeah and it uh was a
picture of um
of harry styles as star fox wow oh
and i guess a reference to the fact that
star fox is uh you know guilty of all
kinds of sexual assault in the comics
and i remember thinking like star fox
there's no way they're gonna put him in
the mcu because he's a predator and in
fact she-hulk had to represent star fox
as as a client in a sexual assault case
at what point uh but no it was a real
thing and then shortly after that i saw
eternals and i was i was bummed that i
was spoiled and then uh later i found
out that when you blow that whistle it
makes pat and oswald sound of when he
goes
[Laughter]
wow that is that's a crazy spoiler
that's insane that's why that is the
craziest spoiler you've i've ever heard
i what a seemingly controversial and not
profitable uh piece of merch they would
make that yeah
i mean i don't think profit in fairness
to them it was probably handed out for
free i think you know oh still a major
spoiler and i gotta say like you know
it's it's uh it's a sad world that those
even have to exist but it's even sadder
when you spoil uh the eternals obviously
uh
you know guys
uh obviously uh star fox whistles aren't
the most fun thing in the world
but this has been mandatory fun and in
order to lift the fundus curse i will
now whisper the counter curse
resumes
the show is
yes
very nice
very nice uh
great we've got a couple um couple folks
that have thrown out some fun super
chats first off shout out to clg comics
who uh said appreciate all that you guys
do and hashtag whatnot what not being uh
a platform that both clg comics uh uses
and we've worked in the past thank you
for that um
uh oh okay there's some good uh
kind of things our good friend chrissy
who's always coming in
with some strong facts uh thank you
chrissy she's a uh expert egyptologist
and and has a lot of great information
said that the um
the
soul stone is the only stone you can
hold in your bare hand because the power
of the soul stone doesn't come from what
it
okay and then it doesn't come from what
it gives you it comes from the knowledge
of what you gave up together
i hadn't thought about it that way crazy
i really like that interpretation a lot
i mean the soul stone i feel like we
need to do a whole series on just the
soul stones like marvel needs to show us
everyone who tried to sacrifice someone
to get the soul stone who's also like
is the soul stone like replicable like
if someone else were to go up to that
cliff side and sacrifice someone like
after thanos and hawkeye got it is it
now gone like
i i just want to see everyone who
sacrificed it and and how it's returned
even
like yeah
interesting interpretation
absolutely we've got a couple quick ones
here uh mickey uh asking about the uh
the daredevil revival that's just been
announced which we covered earlier thank
you mickey for uh super chat and there
and then alison becker94 this is kind of
a uh
a nice coincidence uh give us full
reaction episodes of eric watching
season three of the boys well i don't
know about that allison but we are gonna
be covering season three of the boys
here on new rock stars our our after
show boys underground is coming back
along with season three of the boys uh
we're still working out the details of
who's gonna be on that show and things
like that but you can expect weekly
coverage of the boys season three here
on new rockstars and we'll probably talk
about a little bit on the break room as
well because we'll all be watching it
and enjoying it
uh great oh there were a couple polls
that ran during the show today and i
like i mean some of these polls are just
kind of bait for for like are you
excited about uh the daredevil announced
series and of course ninety-one percent
of what that's great exciting yeah
that's good you wouldn't be watching
break room unless you were excited can i
assume that eight or nine percent that
aren't excited are just hardcore netflix
daredevil fans or maybe a little worried
about they're scared um
uh when asked if people want a wong solo
movie 72 percent said yes now i guess
it's it's easy why wouldn't you want
more
marvel movies now if it's like wong solo
movie or um another doctor strange movie
or one solo movie or
a uh another thor movie then the numbers
might be a little different there but
yeah oh producer john coming in i don't
know if everybody could hear that that
wong during the blip could be an
interesting movie
yeah yeah wong is an example like i'm
not gonna
uh say that any of the upcoming titles
in the pipeline are like why that but um
you know there are so many interesting
characters in the mcu uh so i don't know
why we're getting like solo series and
tv shows for some of these characters
and not wonk you know like
long needs his own title
yeah
i agree we all love him can't go wrong
with wong
that's my campaign i'm running out for
president on i noticed you've got that
you've got that full back tattoo that's
right right
it's it's called wrongfully accused and
it's just
me and me and benedict wong both behind
bars with our hands in prayer
oh
we've got we've got a couple just very
nice chats uh carla ibarra saying thanks
for the break room guys it livens up my
mondays to fridays gear to get eric out
of the blue dungeon well we can't
deliver on that and you know we need
eric in that blue dungeon to get us all
those great breakdowns and theory videos
but we appreciate you carla and we thank
you for watching uh and then andrew uh
mcmanama sorry i butchered your name
there five dollars more towards eric's
plane ticket to join the break room in
person oh you better believe anytime we
can get that guy in the 818 you know
we're pulling them this morning until we
die
yeah i i love doing this with you guys i
miss you all so much
we miss you and that's why it's it's a
pleasure when like folks like tommy get
to go to an event with you we've got
some other events in the cooker we might
be coming to a city near you mr voss and
some other friendly faces from the
channel uh but other than that luckily
you get to see his and our faces a whole
lot every day here on new rockstars we
thank you for watching uh this very
special episode of uh the break room
tommy's casting a spell on us and uh
this is this is a brown noise spell so i
think i've gotta run real quick it's too
late
so oh oh eric do you want to give a
quick tease
eric what do we got coming out on the
channel in the next day or two we have
some really fun videos where i did um
something i don't normally do but i love
doing a
vfx and cgi analysis of uh the she-hulk
footage um and uh i don't come out at it
like the like the wizards over at the
quarter crew do they're all vfx artists
themselves i come at it from like
someone who i feel like i know quite a
bit about vfx and we have a whole great
team of of artists and graphics uh folks
here at new rockstars who consulted on
this but i come from it from a narrative
and character perspective so i did an
analysis based off of what we see of
she-hulk and why some of the shots feel
off and why some of them feel totally
fine and really fun um so i'm at the end
of the day really looking forward to
that show and i don't want people to
like dismiss it or reject it just based
off of some unfinished vfx in the
trailer um
so we got that coming out and uh
another theory of mine that the uh
multiverse of madison 838 universe might
be the same universe as the epilogue of
x-men days of future past there's some
interesting evidence pointing to that
possibility so check out that when uh
very nice very nice we've got some great
videos from whitney and mt coming up in
the next uh couple days as well uh so
check those out uh we'll see you
tomorrow uh 3 p.m pacific 6 p.m eastern
for a funky friday edition of the break
room there might be booze getting
consumed i can either confirm nor deny
that uh eric voss might be back can
neither confirm nor deny that we'll find
out uh but we thank you for joining us
we hope you have a great day keep it
gucci to much
[Music]
stroke
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
streaming
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
so
[Music]
you